le débat sur l'indépendance énergétique
des états unis est l'un des principaux
champs de bataille sur lequel
s'affrontent l'administration démocrate
et l'opposition républicaine c'est un
sujet récurrent de la politique
intérieure américaine mais bien entendu
avec le déclenchement de la guerre en
ukraine la pression sur le président
américain n'a pas cessé de croître
jusqu'à cette décision nous assistons
donc à une évolution majeure dans la
guerre économique que les états unis
livre à la russie depuis bientôt deux
semaines soulignons que cette mesure de
joe biden n'est possible que grâce à une
concertation et un soutien trans
partisan du congrès des états unis mais
fait suffisamment rare pour être
souligné et tout à fait typique du temps
de guerre aux états unis alors bien sûr
la mesure aura un impact sur l'économie
américaine même si joe biden a promis
que cet impact serait maîtrisée par
l'utilisation des réserves de pétrole
fédéral elle participera à voir le prix
du brut pour suivre son envol bientôt
historique et frappera donc directement
la vie des américains mais en filigrane
derrière cette mesure il faut voir
l'impact qu'elles pourraient avoir
également sur l'union européenne cette
fois beaucoup plus dépendante des
énergies fossiles russe puisque l'europe
est dépendante à 40% du gaz de moscou et
environ 30% de ses besoins en pétrole or
l'intention du congrès des états unis et
de la maison blanche est bel et bien de
contraindre ou au moins d'encourager les
européens à choisir eux aussi l'embargo
rappelons au passage que les états unis
n'importe pas de gaz russe et que leur
dépendance en pétrole aussi entre 8 et
10 % de leur consommation cette année